one-fifth of Americans and a full third
of adults under 30 described themselves
as spiritual but not religious which is
to say they don't care very much about
God but they find themselves very very
interesting we will discuss this
postmodern theology with Tyler Blonsky
author of the excellent book an
immovable feast how I gave up
spirituality for a life of religious
abundance then in a bunch of news
stories that the mainstream media are
doing their best to hide president Trump
and Secretary of State Pompeo secured
the release of three American hostages
from North Korea our national guard is
actually protecting our national border
what a concept and last night's GOP
Senate primaries show good signs for
Republicans in November I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
it just won't stop can't stop won't stop
more incredible news
one day after Donald Trump burnt down
Barack Obama's entire legacy he has now
gone over to that legacies grave and
relieved himself on the ashes well done
mr. president
so we recall now we recall otto warmbier
this poor American student who was taken
hostage by the North Korean regime
during the Obama administration the
Obama administration couldn't get him
out
president Trump we know now has secured
the release of three American hostages
who had been held in North Korea do you
remember when at Donald Trump he would
send those angry tweets to North Korea
he called little rocket man short and
fat because little rocket man Kim
jong-un said that Donald Trump is old
and crazy and an American president
would've responded say well that's not
very nice don't don't do that normally
you know Barack Obama - no no no and
what does Donald Trump say he says how
dare he I would never call him short and
fat is that yeah he's got a button on
his desk
I got a bigger button and my button
works the whole mainstream media freaks
out they say he's gonna plunge us into
World War three we're gonna have a
nuclear holocaust he doesn't know what
he's doing he doesn't know oh he just
secured the release of three American
hostages Oh Kim jong-un is now doing
what we tell him to do this is a major
diplomatic feat let's tune into the
mainstream media to see all of their
coverage of this incredible diplomatic
feat if the president insists on keeping
us stormy silence he's got a hope that
60 minutes doesn't become 60 days more
details from stormy Daniels Jeanne Mouse
CNN we still stay a little on the stormy
side down in New York
good evening tonight breaking news in
the stormy Daniels story we'll bring you
the latest legal development we'll also
show you my full 60 minutes conversation
with Daniel's tonight along with
portions not shown on last night's
broadcast her attorney joins us as well
so does Michael Cohen's lawyer to
discuss new legal developments late
today I actually wanted to see the clip
so yeah so I want to see the clip of
North Korea coverage because we've seen
you know we've gotten a lot of stormy
Daniels coverage so let's just see the
mainstream media reporting on this great
North Korean diplomatic feat pornstar
stormy Daniels
who's the president's lawyer for
defamation accusing Michael Cohen of
calling her a liar as Daniels goes
public about a religion affair with
Donald Trump and says she was threatened
the White House says the president still
denies an affair and rejects her claims
I'm Wolf Blitzer you're in the situation
[Music]
this is CNN breaking news that that's
not the breaking news what I want the
breaking news is that Donald Trump
secured the release of three hostages
from North Korea just show me that
coverage
Michael Cohen's first statement about
the storming Daniel's payment was on
February 13th I said no more I don't
know I know more mainstream media turn
it off I don't want any more this stupid
mainstream media they this is by the way
this those clips could have been taken
from any moment in the last five months
those guys just any day breaking news
that porn star is still talking that
porn star who wanted to run for Senate
as a Democrat but five years ago or
however long ago she's she's still
talking about she doesn't like Trump and
we end breaking breaking news so anyway
on the actual story where Donald Trump
secured the release of three American
hostages in North Korea the New York
Times The New York Times this is really
the failing New York Times this is the
epitome of the failing New York Times as
Mike Pompeo as the Secretary of State is
in North Korea personally securing the
release of American hostages there
the New York Times runs a headline at
key moment
Trump's top diplomat is again thousands
of miles away and they're saying at the
key moment because the Iran deal was
ripped up yesterday but they'd already
done that that was already a fait
accompli
so Mike Pompeo was busy securing the
release of Americans who are being held
hostage in North Korea the Ergun Times
runs where is he what's he do he's
probably on a beach somewhere in Boca
you know and but what's really weird
about this you can't even chalk it up to
just total ignorance on the New York
Times as part as you frequently can
because the caption on the photo in that
article said that Pompeo was busy in
North Korea trying to deal with the
hostages so was it did the headline
writer just not read the article did you
just not see the the photo it's
certainly incompetence it's certainly
ignorance certainly terrible journalism
but that's the New York Times this by
the way is the argument for Twitter some
of the I don't know how this is still
the case but some of the sophisticate
conservatives and Republicans they say
well trio Trump is doing good I like
Trump but we need to take away his
Twitter his Twitter is ruining him
Twitter is the whole thing Twitter is
the whole presidency without Twitter
none of this happens without Twitter
that's what we get without Twitter it's
just the stormy Daniels presidency you
wouldn't even hear about the North
Korean hostages you just know it's just
stormy slate let's have let we've only
had Mike avenatti the stormy Daniels
lawyer on 15 times today we go we still
have a couple hours left in the day
that's what we would get so let's hear
it from Donald Trump himself call it a
confidence-building measure a goodwill
gesture you could describe a number of
different labels to it but the bottom
line is three Americans who have been
detained for some time in North Korea
are on their way home right now and the
president very happy about it
tweeting just a few minutes ago quote I
am pleased to inform you that Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo is in the air and
on his way back from North Korea with
the three wonderful gentlemen that
everyone is looking so forward to
meeting they seem to be in good health
also good meeting with kim jeong-hoon
date and place of the summit with
President Trump said the president also
suggesting he's going to be up late
tonight secretary Pompeo and his guests
will be landing at Andrews Air Force
Base at 2:00 a.m. in the morning the
president tweeted I will be there to
greet them very exciting it's why I love
these tweets because you get the words
from Trump himself he tweets it out but
then his tweets become the news that the
fact of his tweeting is the news and as
Fox News just said that is the bottom
line the bottom line is that Donald
Trump secured this release that Mike
Pompeo secured this release that the
Republican administration secured the
release of hostages which the Obama
administration was not able to do that's
the bottom line and that's a that's a
really good thing it cuts through all
the stormy whatever other nonsense
they're talking about and look at how
Donald Trump is handling this he's by
that that tweet you saw it right there
he's positive he it's it's engaging it's
positive it's grateful and it's a TV
show
it keeps I stay tuned stay tuned for
what's gonna happen we've got this
character going over here this is
happening and he says I'm gonna meet
them they're getting in at 2:00 a.m. I'm
gonna meet them there this is an
important aspect of this whole
announcement meeting them at 2:00 a.m.
is
a signal from Donald Trump to Kim
jong-un to the international community
it's as much for them as it is to score
points on domestic politics because what
he's saying is I'm a vigorous guy I'm
paying attention I am personally
involved in what's going on I don't need
sleep I've got a button on my desk that
actually works what'd he say this is
like when Reagan met Gorbachev for the
first time he was he you know he's an
older man Gorbachev was supposed to be
this young vigorous leader and it was
winter in it was still chilly in
Washington DC so he Reagan was gonna
wear his big overcoat and at the last
minute either his advisers or he decided
to take off the overcoat and he trotted
down those stairs not wearing a coat
just wearing his suit jacket and you
know light little suit jacket and
Gorbachev was all buttoned up and he's
plotting slowly it was this great
display of vigor and Gorbachev actually
brought this up to Reagan he said next
time tell me if we're wearing the coats
or we're not wearing the coats because
it was a total PR win for Reagan and you
see the same thing happening with Trump
Trump is doing this Trump is not a young
man Trump Trump is one of our older
presidents and but he's saying I'm gonna
stay up late I'm gonna be tweeting I'm
gonna be vigorous and informed it was
really really good he also announced
that this summit this possible summit
with Kim will not take place in the
Demilitarized Zone in the DMZ we don't
know where he said he'll announce it
within three days there's the reality TV
stay tuned stay tuned don't miss the
next episode very optimistic but he
keeps saying everything could be
scuttled so keep playing nice Kim
because if Kim doesn't play nice they'll
cancel the whole meeting and there it
goes
now when forget the tweets here is a
clip of Donald Trump in on video
describing this feat himself everyone
thinks so but I would never say
you know what I want to do I want to get
it finished the prize I want is victory
for the world not for even here I want
victory for the world cuz that's what
we're talking about so that's the only
prize I want I think he's being serious
here we'll get to why this is so
important what this shows us about
politics but before we do that I've got
to thank a wonderful sponsor Lending
Club love Lending Club
we all need a helping hand sometimes
whether it is unexpected repairs or
medical expenses or credit card debt
sometimes a little bit of money can make
a big difference you can get it at
Lending Club com I've had this at some
points in my in my life I've when I was
much younger through a series of
unfortunate events I inherited my house
and the thing that any homeowner knows
is that houses are money pits especially
if they're older houses or whatever and
at the time didn't have a lot of cash
and house it you just need repairs all
the time the roof leaks that this leaks
that and sometimes you just need a
little money to get you by in a pinch
Lending Club gives you access to low
rates on loans of up to $40,000 for
almost any purpose you can take control
of your debt you can finance a major
purchase you can finally make home
improvements just go to Lending Club
comm enter how much money you need and
see if you're approved in minutes pick
the offer that's right for you the money
can be in your account in just a matter
of days it's that simple for more than
10 years Lending Club has helped
millions of people with over thirty 1
billion billion with AB $1.00 in loans
take charge of your finances today with
Lending Club go to Lending Club comm
slash Knowles Keo wles
to check your rate for free this one
impacts your credit score it's really
easy it's the way to do it
do not go you don't have to go to a bank
you do not have to use high interest
credit cards is really simple Lending
Club calm slash Knowles Keo wles
Lending Club calm / Knowles all loans
made by Webb bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender you'd be foolish not to
do it go check it out today so Donald
Trump he says the reporter asks him are
you gonna get a Nobel Prize should you
get a Nobel Prize he says people keep
saying that I wouldn't look I wouldn't
say it everybody is talking event but
when he says what I care about is that
it gets done
I want victory for the world I don't
care about the prize I care about the
victory I think he's being serious I
don't think that's false modesty for
with other politicians
be false modesty with Barack Obama would
be false modesty with him I actually
don't think he cares well we know from
Donald Trump is he doesn't really seem
to care about accolades from other
people now that's not to say he doesn't
care about accolades he loves accolades
he slaps his name on everything that
he's ever been a part of but he does it
himself
he doesn't beg and say oh please you
give me this or you do this or can you
is always him putting his own name in
lights he's already won the biggest
prize in the world he's the president
the United States Nobel Peace Prize
doesn't does not matter after that but
what he wants is to accomplish the thing
he wants to do the thing this is a major
difference between the right and the
left the right likes the thing itself
securing a denuclearized North Korea at
the at the biggest end of it or at least
bringing in to the Korean War bringing
American hostages back home they like
the thing itself what the left likes is
the appearance of the thing they just
like the appearance just the glitz and
the glamour but not the substance the
husk not the real thing
so Barack Obama was he was nominated for
a Nobel Peace Prize he won the Nobel
Peace Prize he won the Nobel Peace Prize
something like eight and a half months
after entering office he was nominated I
think 12 days after entering office very
quickly that that's but what did what
did he do to deserve it absolutely
nothing he certainly doesn't deserve it
even the left admits that now Donald
Trump wants the real thing that is what
the right should focus on the real thing
forget all the mainstream media articles
and the polls and the bits and the
awards and how nice and the dinners no
just do the real thing get the real
thing it's much more gratifying speaking
of the real versus the superficial let's
talk about being spiritual but not
religious this is one of my favorite you
hear that everyone says it now today
well I'm spiritual but not religious I'm
joined now by Tyler Blonsky Tyler is an
author musician and record producer he
is the author of when donkey when
donkeys talk a quest to rediscover the
mystery and wonder of Christianity and
most recently is the author of an
excellent book that I highly recommend
an immovable feast how I gave up
spirituality for a life of religious
abundance Tyler thank you for being here
hey Michael it's so wonderful to be here
thank you Tyler I can't - is this
just a Catholic thing you look like
you're in matt walsh is set you're
broadcasting from your car into or all
catholics required to broadcast from
cars or broom closets like i am you know
i hope not i was actually gonna go use
the public library i'm on the road today
and i got all set up and kind of like
most government programs it didn't work
the Wi-Fi was was cheap no I couldn't
get cell phone reception so I came
running out here to my car thanks for
your patience I'm shocked not at all not
at all that you know if if we knew you
were using government facilities we
would have given you even a bigger
buffer of time to go use the private
stuff instead so Tyler you know Yura
you're a major heretic you are a huge
heretic and I'm not talking about
religiously religiously or quite
Orthodox but I live in Los Angeles and
out here you would be a total heretic
man cuz it's all about spirituality man
none of those bad religious feels you
know it's just a bad spirituality to
begin before we get into it I really
really enjoyed your book and I think
everyone should go read it what does it
mean to be spiritual but not religious
great question I think my experience of
even with myself of identifying as being
spiritual but not religious was that I
wanted authentic relationship with God
and for a lot of folks that means
there's with the divinity or the good or
the the force that might be with you or
not the universe that you have that a
lot out here they say the universe even
though that that is true truly heresy
because that is a creation rather than
the Creator but I think they're getting
it the same thing the energy the
divinity the god spiritus yeah yeah now
of course as a Christian being spiritual
but not religious I always thought that
for me meant being authentic a truly
deep personal relationship with God that
didn't involve any obligations or rules
or morals that might impose themselves
on me and direct my life right so for me
being spiritual but not religious was
about this personal relationship that
allowed me a wide breadth of beliefs and
practices even if they contradicted each
other I totally understand that I having
having been raised
used a Catholic although I went away
from that for a long time I did always
enjoy st. Agustin's
entreaty to Lord make me chase but not
yet there was just a version of that and
as a kid as you write in the book you
spurned the ritual religious ritual it
was all about faith not works that's
sort of that dichotomy that we hear so
much in popular religion you were a
thoroughgoing antinomian it seems Jesus
saves your free will has nothing
whatsoever to do with it and when I look
around though at this idea of the
performance the performance of ritual
it seems to me spirituality is at least
as performed or enacted as religion and
usually moreso so what is it that
convinced you that this popular theology
was wrong you know what I found out I
just through trial and error it's kind
of funny when I'm when an immovable
feast finally arrived you know found and
looking beautiful I was like all
Brittany to my wife I was like are you
gonna read it and she was like oh no I'm
not gonna read it and she's like are you
and I was like no way because I kind of
like the pigs out I kind of tell too
many stories and they're really like
through trial and error through a lot of
hard one lessons I learned that
spirituality being spiritual but not
religious almost always ends in
disappointment if not loneliness I think
it was Abraham Lincoln who said that if
we won't obey the Ten Commandments we'll
obey the Ten Thousand Commandments right
where if we don't have the real thing
we'll end up making ten thousand
replicas and being spiritual but not
religious I totally did that I would
invent I'd be very religious about
things that weren't religious whether it
was my diet eating organic eggs or
drinking wheatgrass or yoga or just kind
of being dogmatic about being spiritual
but not religious right that's such a
good point you write one of my favorite
sentences in the book is the Catholics
are content with a single Pope and that
he is only infallible when he speaks ex
cathedra but I gladly accepted popes by
the Dozen and they were infallible when
they stood in the pulpit or in their
Birkenstock sandals so you get this
sense and from the quote that you say to
that everybody's got to serve somebody
that if you don't stand for something
you will fall for anything
is there any way
as you see it to escape the strict
boundaries imposed by some religion you
know I actually I think it's deep deep
in our in our nature just as human
beings as men and women to end up
becoming religious we we need to live a
life that has patterns that has
structures that make sense to us and all
of us are telling stories to make sense
of the world we can't help it right we
think and story whatever story you're
telling yourself whatever patterns and
rituals you're you're creating around
your daily rhythms and your
relationships that is your religion
whether you admit it or not you are you
are choosing to conform to something
that is hopefully bigger than yourself
to some degree whether it's politics or
you know some kind of environmental
issue or social justice issue we tend to
get religious we can't help it
the question is are you being religious
in a good way and are you being
religious about what's actually true and
good and beautiful and it's the it's the
culture as if in the culture as you you
quote Russell Kirk making an observation
that we talked about on this show all
the time that there's no culture without
the cult cult and culture come from the
same word and the the spiritual but not
religious types they spurn cults in a
religious organization does this explain
why the spiritual but not religious
types are usually such cultural
Philistines that they don't they have a
sort of narrow culture I think so I have
very good memories of being in college
but also memories that I've been able to
reflect on it where with so many of us
you know so many of us were Christians
we had so much in common or should have
we should have been able to worship
together on Sunday morning but we
couldn't because we disagreed we were
Christians without a culture and yet
every Friday night we could party
together and it's because we all spoke
the same entertainment Billboard Top 100
Hollywood news speak right that was the
common denominator that was the cult
that actually tied us together and
that's to me is tragic I wish that there
was a way we could and I'm working
towards this right with with the book
and a moveable feast how can we recover
a sense
culture that's truly rooted in a cult
that makes sense that's rich and
beautiful and true that's such a good
point what is your what is your cult
what are the things that bind you to
other people what is the common language
if most of us are being honest it's it's
the popular culture it is whenever you
get three Christians in a room of
perhaps some different denominations or
sex or whatever they'll they'll disagree
about everything but we can all agree on
you know going on getting a drink or
something like that that's a really good
point and the Catholics especially can
agree on going out and getting a drink
now you you have been a Protestant
evangelical fundamentalist it seems just
from perusing the book Catholic now I
find that all of when I have a lot of
friends who were Protestants and there
are still Protestants but they say
they're not Protestants or evangelical
or whatever I find all of the non
Catholics or non Eastern Orthodox and in
some cases the Anglicans fall into that
anglo-catholic sphere - but all of the
the fundamentalist types are frequently
quite hostile to the Saints and to the
Virgin Mary they're not simply
indifferent to them they're are
outwardly hostile they said why would
you ever pray to a saint or why would
you ever venerate the Virgin Mary why is
that where does that hostility come from
well having once been quite hostile
myself I think it comes from a
frustration that people keep bringing
into what should be a private
relationship between you and Jesus an
actual community a community that seems
to almost threaten the purity of being
spiritual but not religious so for
example I a big epiphany for me and just
discovering you know the Blessed Virgin
Mary and the communion of saints was
realizing you know when Jesus talks
about the first and second commandments
you know love the Lord your God with all
your heart love your neighbor as
yourself these two Commandments aren't
in competition right even in heaven the
second commandment will be like unto the
first where even in heaven we will love
the Saints and intercede for the Saints
on earth just as we love Christ right
and having the Saints - what what Jesus
is doing which is loving God and loving
neighbor and we see evidence of this
especially in Revelation now good luck
to anybody who can tell me precisely
what revelation means but we see the
Saints holding the prayers worshiping
God in holding prayers who are they
praying for they're praying for those of
us who need the prayers and at that
point is so important you know it's
we're talking about a City of God we're
talking about a community that binds us
to people who are not dead but who have
everlasting life
this some will say why do you pray to
dead people I say the Saints aren't dead
they're the only people we know for sure
or alive as a matter of fact absolutely
that distinction yeah sometimes it can
be lost and people say well it's not
clear it's very opaque but dr. Johnson
told us all shallows are clear all
shallow thinking is clear now now this
has all been too enjoyable so I want to
bring in some terrible news and you can
try to convince me that this is not true
all of the data show us that religiosity
is on the decline now on the flip side
of that you know people like Jordan
Peterson or ben shapiro or andrew
pleavin or other people who explained
about god either explicitly or
implicitly those guys are more popular
than ever the people who were talking
about meaning in life that it there's a
there selling a lot of books and a lot
of young people are listening to them is
this the triumph of spiritual but not
religious or on the bright side is this
the darkness before the dawn of a
religious revival being led by those
people who are talking about God in a I
think I'm mostly explicit way you know I
think what it is is kind of like the
suburban sprawl of spirituality it's
become popular it's so ubiquitous
everyone is spiritual but not religious
and it's just beige and it looks like
when you drive through suburban sprawl
just looks like everyone is living in
the suburbs and there's no hope for
Humanity when in fact I think in the
midst of that there will be Orban
renewal you know there'll be a
renaissance for for farming that kind of
thing I think the same goes for being
religious is there's actually I think a
deep hunger in a longing especially in
young people today for religious
moorings for something that's beautiful
and for a story that's bigger than
themselves that they can participate in
and true religion not not phony religion
right now when you're being a big fake
show but true religion rooted in history
and in Revelation that goes deep and
people are longing for those old
liturgies and traditions that are
actually perennial that's so true I will
say especially speaking of the liturgy
there you know all of all of the
churches I find that have this
watered-down liturgy and you know
they're all the acoustic guitars or
whatever those are emptying out the pews
are emptying out and you see more Latin
masses and more traditional masses even
masses in English but they have some
chanting those are cropping up all over
the place and and the houses are packed
so I do see I certainly see a sign for
hope there what I must say I you know I
read a ton of books for to prepare for
the show I especially loved in a
moveable feast so everybody should go
out and read it it's a really good book
I'll put the link on my Twitter and
Facebook as well Tyler thank you so much
for being here Tyler Blonsky and a
moveable feast hello I gave up
spirituality for a life of religious
abundance probably not gonna make it to
the Oprah book club anytime soon but you
can get it here no Tyler thanks for
being Michael thank you thank you so
much it was such a joy all right
speaking of the spiritual but not
religious a Catholic University has now
opened a sex segregated prayer space to
accommodate Muslim students it's true
story do we have to we have a little bit
of time to get into this I can't let
this story go without mentioning st.
Ambrose University in Davenport has now
opened up a prayer space yesterday that
designates separate areas for male and
female worshipers okay this prompts a
few questions
I'm sure it's prompts a litany of
questions to begin why does a Catholic
University have a Muslim prayer space
those are I don't think Islam is a
version of Catholicism or a denomination
of Catholicism there are this is a
serious question now you might say well
it's a university why can't they have
one right its university it's a Catholic
University there are plenty of secular
universities
America nobody is forcing Muslim people
to go to Catholic universities nobody is
forcing atheists to go to Catholic
universities there are virtually every
university in America is secular these
days most of the top universities most
of the big brand-name universities why
can't the Catholic University be
Catholic well you say what's the big
deal oh what's the big deal if they want
a prayer space that's fine if they want
to keep the men and women apart when
they're praying who cares why can't they
do that at a Catholic University because
it's anti Catholic because it's
anti-christian we know that Christianity
is a religion in Christ is a person
wherein there is neither Jew nor Greek
nor slave nor free nor male nor female
but all are one in Christ Jesus what
Islam says is no well let's not go that
far split those two biological sects
apart so what is the Catholic teaching
on Islam that's another question to ask
oh why can't they have a prayer space
because Catholicism rejects Islam Islam
began actually as a Christian heresy and
it developed into its own separate
religion but there are major differences
here not just that in in one there is
neither male nor female but all are one
in Christ and in the other men and women
have to be kept apart to worship but
also Islam denies the cross of Christ
and st. Paul writes there are many
walking now and I tell you even weeping
who deny the cross of Christ the Quran
states they crucified him not they
crucified him not that's a major
difference what the Catholic University
is teaching here is what we were just
talking about with Tyler spiritual but
not religious be spiritual but not
religious now this is not to say by the
way that we should go out of our way to
offend people or to insult people who
have different religious views but
certainly we should not compromise our
own faith to appease those people it
doesn't make any sense it's ridiculous
that's why this is a news story it is
absurd that a Catholic University has
sex segregated prayer centers for a
religion that denies the cross of Christ
that we know that that's ridiculous
that's the reason people are reporting
on it when you water yourself down this
is
this is the lesson that is beyond just a
religious discussion or whatever this is
true broadly when you water yourself
down when you water your mission down
you do not become better or bigger you
become nothing that's what happens when
you try to broaden out to encompass
everything you don't become broad and
big and all-encompassing
you become nothing there's a story now
the Boy Scouts have become the Girl
Scouts because the Boy Scouts are
allowing girls in they've actually
changed their name the program is now
called Scouts Scouts BSA they took the
boy away well what happened the Mormon
Church has ended its century long
relationship with the Boy Scouts the
Mormon Church has been a huge supporter
of the Boy Scouts for a hundred years
Mormons represent almost 20% of every
person in the Boy Scouts organization
eighteen point five percent of the 2.3
million people involved in Boy Scouts
now they're gone now it's over
they're out of there this is the same
thing that happened to churches when the
Catholic Church watered down its liturgy
watered down it's teaching the pews
emptied they didn't water down doctrine
but they watered down the the practice
of it and the liturgy the pews emptied
same thing happened with all of the
mainline Protestant churches do those
still exist anymore are they are there
still mainline Protestant churches I
think they're ghost towns you just see
tumbleweed going through them on Sundays
the same thing happens to politicians
when politicians try to be everything to
everybody they lose their base they lose
the the people who supported them in the
first place just look at John McCain or
Jeb Bush or John Lindsey these liberal
Republicans who want to appease
everybody they end up like low-energy
Jeb you've got to stand for something
you have to stand for something or you
will fall for anything we've got a lot
of news to get to before we get to it
I'm sorry I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube if you are on daily
wire.com thank you very much you help us
keep the lights on you keep khofifah in
my cup if and by the way I need this cup
the last few days man
I've almost drowned on several occasions
if you're not there please go to Daley
wire.com you will get me you'll get the
under Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show do you hear it do you hear
that right now
I can hear it it's like birds chirping
bells chiming it's because it's almost
time for the next episode of the
conversation featuring me little ol me
Michael Knowles on Tuesday May 15th at
5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific I will be
taking all of your questions and easing
your anxiety by answering all your
questions live on air every query that
has burned in your hearts will be
resolved best of all it's an extra
hour-long dose of little old me which
you know what more could you ask for
I almost certainly will not be wearing
pants that just has sort of become the
rule for the conversation
Alicia Kraus will be there too you like
her that'll be nice this month's episode
will stream live on Daily wires YouTube
and Facebook pages it will be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask questions to ask questions as a
subscriber log into the website daily
wire.com that should be your home page
anyway head over the conversation page
watch the live stream after that just
start typing in The Daily wire chat box
and I will answer questions as they come
in for an entire hour once again get
those questions answered by little ol me
Tuesday May 15th 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific join the conversation huh again
none of that matters all that matters is
this the John Kerry vintage the Obama
vintage the Hillary's aids vintage
they're all tweeting they're all so so
sad they're also go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
all right now we've got to get to all of
the stories that the mainstream media
just doesn't want to cover they just
they refuse to cover we really got to
some of them do you remember you
probably don't remember this because it
hadn't been the news that much when
President Trump deployed the National
Guard to the border so he says I'm gonna
deploy the National Guard because
they're all these people coming through
and they won't let me build the wall yet
so I'm gonna send them there and they're
gonna keep these illegal aliens from
breaking into our country and invading
our country it's working it turns out
it's working that's why you haven't
heard about it if it wasn't working you
would have heard about it all the time
US Customs and Border Protection
officers have apprehended an extra 1600
people who have attempted to illegally
enter this country since April 15th in
just the last couple weeks and that's
thanks to the National Guard troops on
the border so what are they doing there
they're guarding that's in their name
you might expect that they're not
arresting people they're not performing
law enforcement roles but they are
freeing up Customs and Border Protection
officers to do all of the arresting
there's increased surveillance there's
increased communication that's a lot of
extra people 1,600 extra people they
also caught an extra 451 people who were
turned away at the border before then
trying to enter illegally this is really
good now the trouble is we need actual
immigration reform and I don't mean that
in the Marco Rubio way I mean that in
people can't enter our country illegally
because otherwise they're just gonna
they're gonna be caught and released
they're just gonna go through the system
it's gonna be this long thing we need
actual reform and in the meantime isn't
this what the National Guard is for this
is pretty good the National Guard is to
guard the nation and that's what they're
doing they're guarding the nation people
are trying to invade the country and the
National Guard is there and saying nope
go back no no no thank you
this is this is really good this is a
good use of the National Guard I'm glad
that President Trump was able to do it
and we should keep it up because also it
keeps these things in the news and it
keeps clear how many people are crossing
into our border constantly and why you
need to send them back with that we have
a country or we don't have a country as
the campaign said for a long time you
have borders or you don't have borders
you have democratically enacted
legitimately enacted immigration law
that's enforced or you don't it's a
nation of laws or a nation of men we're
a nation of laws we're supposed to be
anyway and so this is great stuff also
before we go I've got a I've got to get
to the excellent electoral news from
last night to all the mainstream media
they are so mmm at that I could taste a
hint of The Washington Post
because the GOP did very well in last
night's Senate primaries so how do you
think the Washington Post reported that
how do you think you say GOP did really
well it is this is really good news
great sign for November no they reported
quote in Senate primaries Republicans
avoid their worst fears you kidding me
are you kidding me people that it cuz
they used to be at least a little bit
clever about how they would attack
Republicans and how they would try to
spin everything to put Republicans in
the worst light now they don't even do
that it's there so there's so much less
sophisticated than they used to be so
the Washington Post reports quote their
battles did not hinge on policy since
all the candidates basically agreed with
the course set by Trump they swung on
attitude style and outsider bona fides
that just isn't true it was they're
trying to make it out like these are
these crazy wonky characters and really
all the voters wanted was blood and red
meat and craziness that isn't true at
all in West Virginia
Patrick Morrissey won there he beat the
kooky candidate Don Blankenship Patrick
Morrissey's the Attorney General he's a
completely normal
well-spoken educated politician and the
kooky guy was Don Blankenship this guy
who's an ex-con he's a cold baron
he called Mitch McConnell cocaine Mitch
he referred to Mitch McConnell's
father-in-law being a [ __ ] and why
that would make McConnell not like him
or something like that that that's the
kooky guy they didn't go for him well
Morris he was a totally normal candidate
sitting officeholder it's very good this
is a big win for Trump too because Trump
said ahead of the election he said vote
against Blankenship he didn't say who to
vote for he said don't vote for
Blankenship vote for Morrissey or
Jenkins and he gave his
explanation he said don't vote for
Blankenship because he won't win in
November the last time Donald Trump said
this in Alabama people didn't listen to
him they they voted for Roy Moore in the
primary and then more lost so we
actually kind of have to thank Steve
Bannon today it's a very hard thing to
lose Alabama as a Republican Steve
Bannon managed to do that for us and it
really scared people into thinking Oh
yikes all right maybe we should we
shouldn't go that crazy and pick
candidates who are unreliable so what
else happened a state representative
Mike Braun he's a self funder he raised
five million dollars DC outsider he beat
congressman Todd ro kita and Luke Messer
in Indiana that's pretty good there
there actually is an outsider he's not
some kooky outsider he's a self funder
he can raise a lot of money and he's a
he's a state representative good
candidate in Ohio
representative Jim Renacci one that's
great where now she also was endorsed by
Trump so these are all good signs but
what's the big takeaway this is good
news because it means that Trump's
support matters and it helps now we
shouldn't expect that in in this off
year election we shouldn't expect that
in these midterms well if we believe the
mainstream media we would think that
Trump would be poison
Trump's endorsement would be total
poison and the voters would do the
opposite of whatever he wants but that
isn't the case actually all of the
polling suggests that Trump is quite
personally popular his approval ratings
have been varying between the 40s to the
low 50s the daily approval rating has
been between 47 or 51 percent we also
know that 57% of Americans think the
u.s. is headed in the right direction
the majority of Americans say the
country is going in the right direction
that's the highest percentage of the
population who thinks that since 2007
since before Barack Obama since before
the financial crash that is a great sign
and by the way the Democrats have
nothing they have nothing they have
stormy Daniels that's why they play it
all day long on CNN and the Washington
Post
there isn't an issue for them to run on
what can they run on they ran the
government for 10 years and everything
went to hell
went to hell in a handbasket then Donald
Trump comes in and 15 minutes later
everything is getting better so what can
they run
we might get peace in North Korea for
goodness sakes that they have nothing to
run on so it's just tawdry tabloid trash
like stormy Daniels Oh what what will we
see here we know that Donald Trump is
going to be campaigning and races where
he can help that looks like it'll be a
lot of races and that will help we know
that two of the so-called toss-up seats
currently in the House of
Representatives they're held by
Democrats and they're in districts that
overwhelmingly voted for Donald Trump so
do we are we really confident the
Democrats are gonna win those seats I'm
not confident of that we know that a
total of 12 House seats currently held
by Democrats or in districts that voted
for Trump now they're not listed as
toss-ups but that's a dozen seats total
that they voted for Trump in 2016
they're currently held by Democrats
what's going to happen the question you
have to ask yourself history is working
against us voter engagement
theoretically should be working against
us although in practice I'm not sure it
is if they voted for Trump in 2016 and
everything has gotten better and all of
his numbers have risen since then which
votes has he lost which votes has Donald
Trump lost though there is one gaffe
that Democrats really tried to seize
upon to cut away some of his support and
that was his comments in charlottesville
early in the presidency you know he said
there are good people on both sides and
they twisted this to say that he was
anti black or supporting Nazis or
whatever which isn't true and it was
totally blown out of proportion
but even so he didn't speak artfully and
so they were able to see his opponent so
that that should be it those should be
the votes and he lost right wrong we
would expect the votes that he lost
there to be among black people right
because a Donald Donald Trump was being
portrayed as this anti black politician
Donald Trump's support among black men
has doubled in the last two weeks
literally doubled which votes has he
lost this is really good news you
shouldn't get complacent we should
remain engaged you've got the entire
mainstream media apparatus against us
the Democratic Party against us much of
the federal bureaucracy against us in
some of the Republican Party so
conservatives need to watch out that's a
lot of people against you you got to go
out to the polls things are things are
looking good there is
on the horizon and if we can maintain
that hope and go out there and and
actually vote you could be in for a
surprise in November okay that's and and
we should we should pray about that too
I don't I don't even mean that glibly
there are serious policies here people
do get hurt when Democrats win elections
to say nothing of the the unborn we're
talking about a huge zealous
pro-abortion Democrat party you're
talking about people losing their jobs
you're talking about people of making
less money you're talking about people
not being able to provide for their
families you're talking about people who
won't take the opioid epidemic seriously
there actually are really real
consequences but mostly I just want to
tie it back into that spiritual but not
religious line go out and read a Tyler's
book in a moveable feast it's really
really good and by the time you're done
reading that I'll be back on the air
tomorrow so make sure you tune and get
your mailbag questions and so we can
answer all of them in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018